bolivia ha celebrado elecciones
regionales y municipales este domingo y
si bien el órgano electoral tiene una
semana para hacer el conteo oficial de
votos empresas encuestadoras y medios de
comunicación han establecido mediante
conteos rápidos y bocas de urna que la
oposición al movimiento al socialismo ha
ganado ocho de las diez principales
alcaldías del país incluida la alcaldía
de la ciudad de el alto donde según
estos conteos se ha impuesto el baco
para la ex presidenta del senado
disidente del partido de evo morales
ella habría ganado con más del 60 por
ciento de los votos también han ganado
las alcaldías de la paz santa cruz y
cochabamba las principales del país los
partidos opositores donde no existe
tanta claridad es en las gobernaciones
pues el movimiento al socialismo el
partido gobernante ha ganado en primera
vuelta en tres de las nueve
gobernaciones sin embargo la oposición
solamente ha triunfado en una es decir
en santa cruz y las restantes cinco
seguir
a un balotaje en el mes de abril